(upbeat music)
- I'm one of the few
people you will ever meet
in your whole life, who is impervious
to the pain caused by eating too much ice.
- What?
- Whoa...
- I just like ice.
(laughing)
- This is the kind of ice they use
to pad your drinks and you get less soda.
- Yeah, you want something that just
really crumbles in your mouth.
- It's the kind of ice
that just sticks together.
Look at that.
- Is this gas station ice?
- [Everyone] Oooh
- This is some hot ice right here.
- This is some top shelf.
- It's like snow.
- They're easy to chew.
- Helluva crunch.
- They're just nice to look at.
- They're all perfectly round.
- I gotta say though, it
still does the clumping thing.
Where it all at once freezes together,
and hits you in the face.
- Doesn't all ice do that?
- No.
- What?
- Carol!
- [Everyone] Oh...
- Oh yeah...
- Did little-itty-bitty-mini cubes
- But are they small enough?
- This is pretty good.
- This is in between a
good cube and a round ice.
- And it sounds really good.
(ice rattling)
- It's the kind that when
you are using a straw,
it gets stuck.
- Good point.
- Right. I'm mad when that happens.
- [Man in blue shirt] Awe.
- This is easily the best of all the ices.
- I can't put this in my mouth.
- That's not the point.
It cools your whiskey.
- It does. It melts it at a good rate.
- But it also doesn't
water down your whiskey.
- It doesn't.
- It's not edible.
- This is bull****.
- Not edible?
What are you, six? This makes
me want whiskey right now.
- [Everyone] Hey cheers guys, cheers.
- Mmm
(red haired woman laughing)
- I feel like ******* Frank Sinatra.
- This is some grown-up-ass ice.
- I was not happy.
- [Everyone] Ooh!
- What is this?
- Why is it so hard?
Look at it, it doesn't
even have any shape.
- What a deceptive ice.
- Wow.
- I don't know. Where is this from?
But they've perfected the round cube.
- It was from the gutter,
is where it's from.
- Ooh! Do you hate it so much?
- I hate this ice.
- [Man in blue shirt] Whoa.
- McDonald's ice was garbage.
- [Red-haired woman] Too hard, too hard.
- In the commercials
it looks great though.
- Yeah, I thought Sonic
was better than that.
- (Red-haired woman) Yes....
I mean, you know, you gotta sometimes
think about what the ice feels in.
- Ella, that was super-philosophical.
- [Man in blue shirt] They agree with you.
Those are great.
- Those are good.
- That was just Chick-Fil-A?
- [Everyone] Yeah!
- We all knew, we all knew.
- Yes.
- This blows my mind because the
context of that ice is so different.
that's being used.
- That's coffee.
- See that changes the whole game.
The best ice is ice
that never gets noticed.
- Yeah
- Mmm
- What a thankless job ice has.
- It turns out that I have lots
of strong feelings about ice
that I never talked about.
- I feel like most people do.